[Music]
foreign
a week since my brief but now Infamous
segment on this show about trans
activist Dylan Mulvaney the Tweet with
that clip has been viewed nearly 20
million times on Twitter alone doesn't
count all the other platforms where it's
been shared and reposted as you know all
I did in the segment was speak honestly
to Dylan and about Dylan a man who
degrades and appropriates Womanhood
while Shilling for child mutilation and
sterilization it does all of it for
profit real women have tried to tell
Dylan how demeaning his woman face
routine is but he only doubles down on
the mockery in response and most
recently he released a video bragging
about what an attractive woman he is and
warning women that he could steal their
husbands quote unquote and this was a
video that provoked my response which I
simply told him the plain and
unvarnished truth about himself that he
is not a woman that he doesn't look like
one but the whole degrading display is
not beautiful or remotely attractive
that he is imitating something he will
never truly be in other words I said out
loud what most people already think but
some of those people the ones who agree
with what I said and were already
thinking it
we're nonetheless very upset by my
remarks and perhaps upset is an
understatement they've called me mean
and cruel and sadistic and this has been
going on for a week now with no sign of
letting up uh they've called me a bully
and a grifter
they've said that I'm only I'm only um
hurting the cause by being so
repulsively honest and remember these
are people on the right or at least not
openly on the left saying this
now I've already addressed the Critics
on the show but the criticism has only
gotten louder and more intense since
then and many conservatives in Media or
at least again people in media who did
not identify as leftists have joined in
the dog pile and what began as a three
or four minute commentary on Dylan
Mulvaney in the middle of an hour-long
podcast on Tuesday has now turned into
something of a demarcation kind of a
dividing line
it's been a very revealing moment
enlightening
um and uh and I think for that reason
it's worth revisiting one more time so
that I can make
or perhaps reiterate or emphasize a few
crucial points
in order to frame those points I'm going
to play a quick Montage of some
right-of-center media figures and
podcasters sharing their criticisms of
my Mulvaney comments and what you'll
hear in these clips doesn't come close
to representing the harshest rebukes
that have been directed at me but they
do capture the basic point that all of
my critics have been trying to make in
one form or another with varying levels
of outrage listen
yeah it wasn't that good well
he was just being mean well I was gonna
say like what what he is saying is
actually genuinely like really mean
Parts yeah the whole thing is true like
it's not it's not like it's untrue it's
not like
Del Mulvaney is a male and he will
always be a male and no matter how much
makeup or face feminization or whatever
you'll always be a man this is like a
reality I have a lot of contempt for
these people like a lot of content
you're talking about like Woman face
people you're not talking about math
yeah right well I sometimes have
contempt from that but but less often
than I have content for Dylan Mulvaney I
have I I get where he's coming from
because like I have so much contempt for
these people and the more that this
drags on and the more that they
denigrate females the more that anybody
denigrates females the more angry I get
and the more contempt I have for people
who participate in that in whatever form
that comes in
um
I don't know how I don't know if there's
a necessity or a point in just being
like mean here's my take on it is uh
and I you know obviously I'm much softer
generally but like there's nothing he
said that isn't true but it accomplishes
nothing yeah all it does it's just so
mean that like
it won't resonate and it won't change
minds and I will absolutely say yeah
it's mean
yeah Matt Walsh is being mean I mean
come on Matt Walsh insults Dylan
Mulvaney as Eerie weird and bizarre you
can get the point across without saying
that the major divide on this video is
whether or not the language was a little
too harsh towards Dylan you guys know me
you watch my show you know how I talk
about these issues I am on the side of
this being uh too harsh and I know there
are many who will Who will disagree with
me but to me
there is no need for vitriol I mean
do you reckon he's into her
it so it does look like the sort of
thing somebody would say that when
they're slightly obsessed with somebody
yeah exactly look factually he's not
wrong yeah is he no
actually yeah
I I don't look if your job is to win
hearts and Minds
I don't think this is the best way of
doing it what if it's your job to get
clicks online again but do clicks lead
to changing of opinion no I I don't
think he's trying to change anyone's
opinion what do you think he's trying to
do then
uh
trying to make people on his side feel
like he's done something cool and said
something that they think I think
do you think that yeah yeah well you're
not trying to change it yeah I
completely agree I completely agree I
just I just look at that and just go
even people on his own side were like
hold on a bit mate
okay so that was uh Temple Jeremy from
the YouTube channel the quartering Cindy
Watson Amala ekpenobi from Prairie
prageru and the guys from the podcast
trigonometry now one thing I want to be
clear about here is that I'm not mad at
any of these people there are no hard
feelings we can disagree and all that
it's fine I could have done without the
snagness and the lame cheap shot from
the trigonometry guys at the end
especially in the video where they're
supposed to be lecturing me about the
value of taking the high road okay when
you're going to do that you can't start
the video by insulting me but we'll
leave that uh to the side for now
instead all I'd like to do is address
the overarching criticism one last time
first
you'll notice the connecting thread okay
they all agree that I'm right that what
I said is factually correct but I think
that it goes too far by saying it out
loud
Mulvaney's the one running around like
some cartoon of a woman passing out camp
pods in the women's room and meeting
with the president to defend the
mutilation of children but I went too
far
well see this is where we differ
because in the culture War
I don't think it's possible to go too
far by speaking truth the truth is the
truth it is what it is
it's the reality are we going to defend
it or are we going to conceal it are we
going to embrace it are we going to hide
from it you can't have it both ways when
it comes to gender ideology the truth is
ugly it is brutal and harsh and
disgusting I wish it wasn't that way but
it is I didn't make it that way I didn't
create the ugliness
I'm merely pointing to it and saying
look at this look at it for what it is
but you would rather that I soften the
blow a little bit that I dress the truth
up to make it prettier more palatable
you want me to lie to protect the
feelings of our enemies and make no
mistake Dylan Mulvaney is our enemy
he is an open visible active and
passionate advocate for the abuse of
children the war on fundamental truth
and the destruction of human society as
we know it
you wish to defeat this man in a manner
that will not make him feel bad about
himself but I'm here to tell you that
you are delusional
I'm not going to protect your feelings
any more than I'll protect his you are
deluding yourself
we got into this position in our culture
precisely by valuing politeness over
truth we got here by doing exactly as
you would have me continue doing
and what you blame me for not doing
we got here by refusing to speak the
plain truth and by allowing the
anti-truth Brigade to emotionally
blackmail us into silence they use their
own mental fragility as a cudgel to beat
us into submission
that's the threat right
and we let them get away with it
or you do anyway I won't
second
um
you say that I'm I'm not going to
convince the other side with this kind
of rhetoric
but here's what you have to understand
this is very important
convincing the other side is not my
primary objective
this is the core difference between you
and me
I'm not looking to reach an
understanding with these people
I'm not interested in compromise and
dialogue
for those who castrate children and
attack the very concept of Truth and
erode the foundations of human
civilization
my goal is to defeat and humiliate and
demoralize them
okay I want to destroy everything they
stand for
the other side is not interested in
compromise
they want nothing less than your
unconditional surrender
we have to meet them with that same
energy or we will lose or continue
losing
and by the way
this is also a good strategy because it
rallies people to our side it emboldens
the troops it lets people know that it's
okay to speak up and to speak truthfully
you know it's often said that um
that you shouldn't preach to the choir
that's basically what they were saying
at the the end of that clip there
just a Pandora just pandering to his own
audience he's he's this is a message
that's meant for his own audience well
God forbid
God forbid I speak to my own audience on
my podcast
now preaching to the choir is a good
thing we need to do more of it
because if the choir is demoralized and
scared and cowering in silence then you
damn well better preach to them
what kind of congregation can you hope
to have when even the choir is too
afraid to sing in our choir those who
agree with us the many millions of them
have been cowed into submission they are
nervous they are timid like you
and then you come along and say that we
should ignore them and instead tailor
our message for a group that hates us
and will hate us no matter what we say
or do
this is not just morally wrong it's also
terrible strategy okay it is a dumb
strategy
in fact it's exactly what the churches
have done for decades
and it's why most of them are dying they
water down their preaching to appeal to
the crowd a crowd that isn't interested
in the message no matter how softly it's
peddled
and while at best because they did that
they they bore to death and it worse
actively alienate the very people who
are actually sitting in the pews
so that's what the churches do the
people sitting in the peoples who come
to hear it and then they give their
preaching which is designed to appeal to
people who are outside the building and
not even sitting there
but the people they're outside the
building they don't come in to hear any
more of it instead the people that are
actually sitting there get up and leave
conservatism has made the same mistake
and at what point do we learn the
lessons that our own recent history
seeks to teach us
now
you say that we can't
win hearts and Minds by being nice
Because by the way I'm not saying
that we're only preaching to the choir
it's not that's not it we also do want
to convince people
but guess what
you don't convince people by being nice
you don't
at least not on a cultural level
I mean where did you get this idea where
did you arrive at this conclusion that
the way to win the culture is by being
nice is that how the left won the
culture
have you been paying attention at all
they have seized hold of our society
indoctrinating entire generations and
they didn't do it with niceness they
didn't win these flies with honey
they did it by being bold and aggressive
and by making their oppositions
arguments seem not only wrong
but utterly horrific and insane
that's how they did it
see it turns out that the tone of your
argument is often more important than
the substance of it and the tone that
actually wins the day on a cultural
level is the one that is unwavering and
which Paints the opposition as so
repulsive that you shouldn't even take
their position into consideration
now
the only difference is that they do that
to us dishonestly right they make the
truth seem insane
but what they're peddling actually is
insane
we have allowed them to make the truth
seem crazier than actual craziness
okay we take their ideas more seriously
than they take hours but their ideas are
insane lunacy
and we lend them more legitimacy than
they will lend to us when we are
speaking the truth and they are babbling
nonsense
you think this is a good strategy
what is the evidence that this strategy
works
we moderate our tone we seek to kill him
with kindness
while they recruit Legions by doing
exactly the opposite again I ask you
when will you learn
now finally
if you sense anger in the words that I
use when discussing this topic you're
right that is one crime I will confess
to I am angry
when I look at what these people have
done to our country the devastation they
have wrought on a generation of children
and adults alike
the bleakness and ugliness of their
worldview the moral and intellectual
chaos they leave and they're awake yes I
get very angry
and when I consider that my own children
must inherit this culture that Dylan
mulvanians and his ilk will Prey Upon my
children and try to turn my own Sons and
Daughters into mute mutilated mutant
self-loathing Hollow Twisted shells just
like themselves
well my anger then turns into a more of
a boiling rage
and I know that I will do whatever is
necessary and I will speak whatever
truths are necessary
to protect my kids from this hellish God
forsaken Madness
now
I have personally heard from many
parents
more than I can count
who tell me versions of the same Horror
Story
a beautiful and innocent kid one day
seemingly out of nowhere gets sucked
into the gender occult and is devoured
by it
the child they held as a baby and raised
and gave their lives to and loved and
still loved
become suddenly unrecognizable
all of their innocence and light and
Beauty just drained out of them replaced
by this self-cannibalizing madness
for a parent to see this happen to a
child it is a fate worse than death I
would rather be dead than have that
happen to my kids
see the thing that I most despise about
Dylan Mulvaney is that he is part of a
movement which actively seeks to turn my
children into Dylan Mulvaney
that's why I'm entitled to my anger
and to whatever language I use to convey
it
I will say whatever I want to say and I
will be justified in saying it because
these people are after my kids
and yours
and everyone else's
and you're worried that I'm being a
little rude
well you see when it comes to my
children
the children that I cherish more than my
own life
if you think mean words go too far
then you would be very shocked to hear
how far I would really go to protect
them
trust me words are the least of it
so yes
my words reflect anger because I am
angry
but the problem is not that I'm angry
the problem is that you
aren't nearly angry enough
and that is why the be nice
conservatives are finally today cancel
I'll move over to the members block if
you're not a member yet become a member
and use code wall should check out for
two months free on all annual plans hope
to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]